Prof: Anybody here
happen to be from Korea?
Are you born there?
Student: Yes
Prof: Are you from Seoul?
Student:  Yeah.
Prof: You may know about
this, okay.
There's a--do you know about
the oldest tree in Seoul?
Student: No.
Prof: This is the oldest
tree in Seoul.
It's a Gingko tree,
and it's supposed to be 840
years old, that's a really old
tree and it's venerated by the
residents.
It's kind of a holy sacred tree
and they bring fruit,
they bring other offerings once
a year and pray,
among other things,
for their safety.
Its real advantage is that it
helps pregnant women to have a
boy child and so this is a very
important tree.
Do you know about this tree?
Student:  No.
Prof: No.
Student:  But I've heard
about Gingko trees and how they
have to do with fertility and
stuff.
Prof: Yes,
okay Ginkgo is one of the few
kinds of trees that have male
and female sex.
Most trees are hermaphrodite,
have both male and female sex.
Anyway, it turns out they ran
into a problem with this tree
because two apartment buildings
were interfering with the trees
roots as the tree spread its
roots.
What happens--so the district
government spent $4.3 million
dollars to take down the
apartment buildings.
So it just goes to show you the
importance and the political
acceptability,
the cultural acceptability of
son preference.
It's a very,
very big factor in the world.
The sex ratio,
is a very important biological
factor, if we have time at the
end I'll tell you a good bit
about it.
Just to show you that it's very
well controlled biologically,
this is one of several theories
about how the sex ratio in
humans gets to be what it is.
The sperms are 50/50.
There's 100 male sperms to 100
female sperms and that's because
the sex is determined by the
father and the father has one X
and one Y,
and when they split to go into
separate sperms one gets an X,
one gets a Y,
that's even.
By the second month of
gestation, so this is still in
the mother's womb,
apparently a huge fraction of
about one-third of the male
fetuses have died,
leaving--I'm sorry the female
fetuses have died because now
it's a high male ratio.
Then as time goes on the male
fetuses start to die and when
you end up, you get 106 at birth
all over the world unless people
are messing with it.
There's about 106 male births
to every 100 female births.
This is a very,
very fixed number,
so for instance,
in the United States in 1969
there were 105.3 males born per
100 females;
1995 30 something years later
104.9, so difference of .4.
That number really does not
vary except basically between
105 and 106.
It's a very, very stable number.
Given that, you can look at
some parts of the world and see
something like this.
This is again the sex ratio and
you can look over time,
1972 to 1992 a 20 year span and
here is Japan where they started
a little bit of X--
here's the numbers you should
expect,
somewhere in this range.
They have somewhat of an excess
of boys but very minor and than
during this period of time Japan
came down to almost exactly that
106 number.
Look at what's going on in
China, up to 113 or so,
which means basically seven out
of every 100 girls are being
done away with 7%.
That's not anywhere near the
worst case.
What do you think is the cause
of this?
Student:  Mitochondrial
DNA.
Prof: Mitochondrial DNA?
Student:
>
mitochondrial DNA can choose to
eliminate male fetuses.
Prof: So you think it's
a very long term evolutionary--
what she's saying is she
thinks--there's stuff that--
the Y--the sperm--the Y
chromosome has very few genes,
the X chromosome has many genes.
There looks like there's a long
evolutionary process by which
genes are getting eliminated on
the Y,
and eventually the Y will then
have nothing on it and
disappear.
This is much too short a time,
we're talking ten years,
evolution just doesn't happen
in ten years but it's a good
thought.
Student:  Does it have
something to do with the
implementation of the one child
policy;
people wanting sons as opposed
to daughters.
Prof: Very good.
This is the most usual answer:
the one child policy in China.
This is China remember and the
one child policy,
so people have heard of the one
child policy and I'm going to
give a lecture on it.
Does that sound like a good
hypothesis to you?
But just saying it doesn't make
it true, so what else did--
Student:  This is at
birth.
Prof: This is at birth.
Student:  How could
you--even if you wanted sons I
presume that the greatest way to
manage that would through
infanticide and you can't do
that until after birth.
Prof: Very good idea.
What she says is look this is
at birth.
Students:
>
Prof: Good,
I'm glad all this discussion.
Let's notice one other thing.
One child policy,
when does the one child policy
start?
We'll come back to these
explanations;
they're all good.
Anybody know?
Guess what, about 1979,1980.
When does this take off?
That looks like now we've got
at least a second piece of
evidence that it's--the time
sequence fits very nicely with
the one child policy.
How can we check that?
We're still--we have to be very
skeptical about everything that
anyone tells you;
that's the scientific attitude.
Anything anybody tells you,
politics,
science, religion,
economics, try to sell you
something,
immediate gut response is
'that's nonsense prove it to
me.'
I'm not convinced yet so what
else might you do?
Student:  If you can
find data on abortions.
Prof: You could find
data on abortions,
good.
We'll look at that when we talk
about China.
We might look at other
countries that don't have the
one child policy.
Here's another country,
this is India,
and you have--remember the
Chinese--and this is a somewhat
different data set.
This is not at birth but the
total population which is less
extreme,
but a comparable number for
China would be here,
so India is more extreme than
China.
Student:  India is a bad
example because bride prices are
so high that they
>
Prof: There are reasons,
other reasons in India,
there's clearly reasons all
around and they may be different
in different places but the main
hypothesis that we are working
on it and come back to it,
it's very important.
The main hypothesis that we're
working on is that it's one
child policy in China.
Now we see that China is not
particularly extreme say
compared to India.
It depends on what year you
look and exactly what statistic
you look at.
It's really in the same
ballpark with India.
Now we have to say that well,
it's probably not one child
policy.
What's our next hypothesis?
We've heard a different one for
China.
India has bride price but than
if you start with India and say
that, China doesn't have bride
price;
they have dowry,
they may have in fact the
opposite.
What about--
Student:  Is it sex
selective abortion?
Prof: That's something,
but why are the women doing it?
Poverty, that's the usual thing
when you speak of India and
China.
In these years they were still
very--they're still quite poor
but it was poverty.
How does that strike you as a
hypothesis for this?
Or part of it,
these things are multi-causal.
Student:  China's
economy has been taking off but
it's the--ratios are still going
up.
Prof: Well the only--
I'm going to show you that data
but I only showed you the data
up to 1990,
1992 so I haven't--I'm going to
show you that.
Again we can go to an
international comparison if we
want to see if poverty is at the
root of this,
and what are we looking at
here?
Korea, South Korea.
Korea is not a poor country and
yet they're just as bad,
in fact a little bit more
extreme than China at this time.
We really have quite a
conundrum that we can give
particular explanations for each
place but they're maybe going to
be different.
Student:  Is it maybe
just population growth in
general?
Prof: It could be
population growth in general,
that's certainly true of all of
the three countries.
That there's something about
the density of population;
hard to prove since India and
China have been very crowded for
a very long time and Korea is
also crowded but not as
extremely as China and India.
Not--the greatest sex ratio is
in South Korea,
which is, as you heard,
is not poor and by 2010 there
will be a 20% deficit in the
marriage age,
there will be a 20% deficit of
females in Korea which is quite
high and that's done away with.
The poverty thing,
the economic thing does not
work between countries,
and even if you look,
I'll show you a little bit
later,
there's big regional variations
within each country but it
doesn't go with economics at
all.
In China, in Guangdong,
where everything you're wearing
and everything you play with,
including probably this is made
somewhere in Guangdong Province
probably.
It's one of the richer places
in China and the sex ratio there
is 130 to 100,
something I've showed you 12 to
14,
in that province it goes up to
130 and parts of that province--
so of course even within a
province there's different
places,
they can go up to 144 to 100,
so something like a third of
the girls are done away with.
Student:  Provinces with
such a skewed sex ratio,
do they end up paying dowry or
these bride prices because
females are so rare?
Prof: No bride price
doesn't happen in either China
or India;
bride price,
you remember,
is when the man's family gives
something to the girl or the
girl's family,
dowry is the opposite and dowry
is common in India and really it
was--
communists got rid of it,
any vestige of that in China so
that's not the case.
In India the same thing,
the states in New Delhi and
Haryana, which are the richer
places there,
have more extreme sex ratios
then poor places.
There's--in Delhi there's 861
females per 1,000 males at birth
and so as time goes on,
as you see, the sex ratios are
getting worse.
The answer to our problem of
what is causing--what caused
things to change at this point
in time is what someone here
said.
What did someone say,
something that would have--
it wasn't the--is the one child
policy happened at this time but
something else happened in both
India,
and China, and Korea.
Student:  Did it have to
do with technology in terms of--
Prof: It has to do with
technology.
Student:  for sex
selection prior to birth.
Prof: For knowing the
sex before birth and what--
Student:
>
Prof: What is the
technology that's commonly used?
Student:  Ultrasound.
Prof: Ultrasound,
that at that time ultrasound
came in and became rather
inexpensive and available.
The two ways of doing it are
amniocentesis,
which is somewhat difficult
medically and quite expensive,
but ultrasound you don't need
an awful lot of training,
the equipment is not terribly
expensive.
It costs I think about $14 in
India, in this period of time,
to get an ultrasound test of
what your fetus was.
In one of the counties in
China, for instance,
they started doing ultrasound,
and what happened was the first
child,
and I'll show you some data,
that was okay if it was a girl.
But, if the second--if they had
a first girl and the second
child was also a girl,
then 92% of the time the girls
would be aborted.
I think in your reading it
talks about in India--they
looked at 8,000 serial abortions
in a particular hospital and
7,999 were females.
One was a male and that was
probably a mistake they just
read--didn't read the ultrasound
right, it's not always easy to
do it.
What's happening is that,
in India and in China it's
illegal in both places,
but they have even sidewalk
clinics that you can just go and
get a little ultrasound.
How many of you have had some
sort of ultrasound?
Yeah it's very--they take a
little probe about that long and
this and just run it over you
and get a picture on a TV screen
and you know,
whatever, your heart,
or your lungs,
or your baby,
whatever is going on.
That's what's going on,
it's the cheap ultrasound.
Doctors in a lot of
places--doctors--
it's so fast to do this,
it's so cheap,
it doesn't take much skill,
that in a lot of places doctors
are just giving up all the rest
of their practice and just doing
ultrasound.
It's sort of like liposuction
here or something.
It's easy and cheap and they
make a lot of women--a lot of
money with this.
The head of the Women's
Association in India says,
"No one wants girls;
if the test says a girl then
the pregnant woman will have an
abortion."
Someone else also mentioned
this I think,
that the final sex ratio not at
birth as we said,
the hint as one of you picked
out, the fact that this is at
birth means it's not an
infanticide issue.
This is something done before
birth,
the only thing you can do
before birth is sex selective
abortion so it's clearly the
mechanism of this and the timing
is clearly the introduction of
ultrasound.
The total sex ratio of the
countries hasn't changed all
that much.
Then, in China we have pretty
good data and traditionally
where-ever one has data there
has been a dearth of about 10%
to 25% of girls from--
they have data back to the
1700s, that's pretty decent.
Back then it was infanticide so
what you're really seeing is a
change of method that the
society is going from an
infanticide control of the sex
ratio to an ultrasound and sex
selective abortion control of
the sex ratio.
Apparently the desire and the
cultural desire for males hasn't
changed all that much,
but technology has changed what
they do and to most people's
mind--
an abortion is a better thing
than an infanticide but you can
make up your own mind about
that.
Let me give you some more data
on the various questions that
you've all asked.
One is an update in time so
that particular slide stopped
in--in that particular data set
stopped in 1992 and this picks
up a little bit later.
Here is again India,
five states there,
and in the most extreme states,
which again are the richest not
the poorest.
This is of course--these are
rich states, this is southern
states, there are all these
different reasons and we'll come
to that in a moment.
Here we saw ratios of 114 or so
and now they've gone up to 129
and slowly getting better,
a little bit better with time
out to the last census in 2006
data.
These are two well off
provinces and they are in
extreme southern India is--
in North India they speak
Hindi--mostly Hindi related
languages,
in the south Dravidian related
languages.
The Muslim invasions didn't
quite reach the south of India,
a lot of differences between
north and south India.
In terms of demography or a
culture, almost anything,
it's crazy to talk about India.
You cannot talk about India;
it's so diverse.
China, they've convinced the
people that they're one culture,
but in India that's not the
case.
So you really have to compare
this as a kind of--these two
states as one kind of country
and they are very close to the
106 level.
This is--and also,
just weirdly in most places,
it's the number of boys to
girls, but in India the way they
define sex ratio is the opposite
so I've translated into these--
these are the numbers that are
comparable to what you've been
hearing.
That's India.
Here is China,
and again it has gone more
extreme, so we stopped here
about 1992 in the 112 range.
This is at birth,
age zero, so we're looking at
this line that's here,
and that has now gone up to 118
or 119,
the sex ratio at birth,
and then as the child grows
older,
as the set of children that
you're counting grows older,
the sex ratio gets more and
more skewed as time goes on and
we'll look at that in a little
bit.
It is very diverse.
I mentioned this,
very diverse by province,
here again is India,
so Kerala as I mentioned to
you,
they're very poor,
Kerala is a very poor state in
India,
one of the poorest,
but they had a communist
government for a long time and
very matriarchal,
their traditional system
was--not matriarchal,
matrilineal so women have more
power.
For a lot of reasons Kerala has
been doing very well on social--
indicators of social progress
and look at it's--
this is child mortality from
zero to five through the first
five years here.
Males 6 per 1,000 male death;
4.5 females, very low deaths;
compare that to Bihar ,
a very poor state where 50 or
60, up to 70 almost deaths.
It's a factor of 10 or 15 for
females, the difference between
different states in India and
the same thing in China.
Here is--what I wanted to show
you about that slide was--well
forget it for a minute.
This is China and you have
again very different--
this is sex ratio at birth,
SRB, sex ratio at birth and
over different periods of time
1982,
1990 and so forth--notice in
between the green which is a
normal ratio,
even bias toward females,
this is almost within the
normal range.
This would be bias toward
females and Tibet,
the far western provinces are
even normal or even bias toward
females and that is a cultural
difference because these are
Muslim provinces and the Koran
forbids the killing of
daughters,
so Muslim countries in general
do not have these very skewed
sex ratios.
Tibet of course is Buddhist and
they also don't do this,
but in the Han regions,
the heartland of China,
especially around 2000,2005 a
very high ratio 120 to 138 and
is changing a little bit slowly,
so as time goes on you see they
go from the 112 that we talked
about,
the blue regions they are
being--disappearing and you're
getting a more extreme situation
here in China.
Again you can pick out;
depending on if you look at
more culturally homogenous
regions, you get either very low
numbers or very high numbers.
Now here's another thing which
I mentioned, it depends terribly
much on parity,
how many children they already
have.
For a first birth,
this is China,
and going out to the year 2000
and this is the--
this is parity here and this is
the different censuses so the
latest census 2005 I think is
this census here and for first
birth it's 107--
it's pretty normal,
a little bit elevated but by
second birth it goes enormously
up and you're into like 140 or a
prior census 150,
so a 50% difference in boys and
girls,
and that extreme there is the
one child policy is pushing that
because they're only allowed--
we'll talk a lot about that.
This is not really true anymore
but in principle they're allowed
only one child,
so you get these very high
ratios here and then by three
children,
four or five children,
the sex ratio is enormous.
You may sort of have a little
thing in your mind,
wait a minute one child policy,
and here they're having one
child,
they're have two children,
they're having three children,
they're having four children,
they're having five children,
what's going on and we're going
to talk about that.
Here is--and again you don't
want to nail this too hard to
the one child policy because
here is South Korea and again
this is all old-time but look
what it goes up to,
the same thing.
You look at the most recent
numbers on this graph and for
first birth it's quite a normal
ratio,
second birth it gets bigger,
by third birth it's bigger than
anything we see in China,
and by fourth birth its way,
way up, over 237.
We saw about 160 or something
in China on the previous slide.
Again, Korea,
no one child policy,
no government control of
fertility at all,
and yet they are more extreme
than China.
At birth, the genetic
factor--boys have an X and a Y
chromosome, and girls have two
Xs.
Humans, as well as every other
animal, carry a lot of
deleterious or even lethal
mutations, but you have them on
only one chromosome.
The other chromosome will
have--in general will have a
normal copy of the gene and for
almost every gene one normal
chromosome makes enough of the
proper protein,
and you're alive,
you're fine,
you don't even notice that
you've got this deleterious
mutation there.
It's only when you get a
mutation from both parents that
it becomes--
it's homozygous,
you're getting the deleterious
mutation with both parents,
than the person is sick.
That works for all the
chromosomes except for the sex
chromosome.
A female has two Xs so this
still holds for her.
She's got to be really unlucky
and get bad copies from both
mother and father.
A male has one X and the Y with
almost nothing on it,
so if he gets a bad X he's
sick;
so males are weaker.
One of the thoughts about why
106 males are born for every 100
females is that as time goes on
those males die during childhood
because they are genetically
weaker and eventually it evens
out to 100.
There's good evolutionary
reasons why evolution pushes a
sexually reproducing species to
100 males and 100 females and we
can go into that later perhaps.
You're seeing that--this is at
birth, right around birth which
is still genetic reasons,
and this is all of India.
You see that now the male
deaths are higher than the
females.
This is a sign of the genetic
weakness of males at birth.
When you break that down by
state, every single state 54:40,
there's more male deaths 71:68,
so what do we have--
one of the Punjab which had a
high pro-male ratio but at birth
there's more male death than
female death,
so that's a biological
phenomenon;
that continues.
If you look later to child
mortality,
now we're done with the birth
we're done with sex selective
abortion,
that the sex selective abortion
itself changes the sex ratio but
then,
even after that,
the sex ratio keeps changing.
Here again is in the first five
years after birth and notice
again in Kerala where they don't
have this sex selective--
this sex choice and I showed
you this,
more males die than females.
That's again the normal
biological issue,
but in every other state,
females are--
this is two and a half times as
much,
this is four times as much
female mortality,
one and a half times as much,
more than twice as much,
twice as much,
half again as much.
Then, in all the states of
India, with the exception of
Kerala, there's an excess female
mortality after birth.
That's counter-biological,
and what that is,
is basically some infanticide,
but largely female neglect.
They get less food,
they get less good food,
they get sick,
they get taken to the doctor
less often,
if medicines are required they
don't get it very well.
So you see this after birth
reduction in females also.
The problem just keeps
happening.
This issue of the loss of
females in a population is a
very large phenomenon.
Statistics--well from this data
you can make fairly decent
statistics for places where this
is collected,
so in India alone,
there's supposed to be
something like 23 million women
missing,
so add all this up and you get
23 million.
In the world the--somewhere
between an estimate and a
guesstimate is 100 million
missing women.
You could say when you look
deeper,
more deeply,
we have the sort of the
proximate cause,
people are using sex selective
abortion but we haven't touched
much on the question of why do
they want to do that.
You can just say it's
traditional.
And I hear a lot of discussions
that say that and this is true.
In India's first national
census, which is 1871,
there were 98 million males but
only 91.5 million females,
already 6% of the females were
missing.
Whereas, in a population which
doesn't discriminate against
females,
males being weaker all during
the ages,
there get to be more and more
females and with the older ages
extreme excess of females,
but in India already in 1871
there was quite a difference.
In China--this is a Chinese
book of travels from the
nineteenth century and someone--
a Chinese person went to
India--went to England and
observed things and came back
and wrote a travel book for the
Chinese and this is a quote from
that: "England is so short
of inhabitants that the English
rear every child that is born.
Even prostitutes who bear
children do not destroy
them."
England was the dominant power
of the world and they were
invading China with the Opium
Wars,
so of course everybody
including the Emperor was
interested in what is England
like,
how come they're so powerful,
what's different there,
and so the Emperor read this
and the Emperor's response was,
he didn't believe that the
English were so stupid.
Again, the cultural thing that
to raise up all the children,
and especially to raise up all
the girls, is just not going.
In your reading packet,
it discusses villages in India
dating back to 1830 that have no
girls at all.
They just do away with all the
girls, all of them are killed.
1921, Somerset Maugham,
does that name ring any bells?
He was a famous author,
wrote a lot of novels,
a lot of movies with very
famous movie stars,
a very popular author.
In 1921 he was touring China
and he came upon a little tower
on a Chinese hillside with a
single small hole in the wall,
so they're walking along and
there's a small tower with a
little hole in the wall.
Out of that hole came a
nauseating odor and he asked--
he was with a Chinese guide and
he asked him what is that,
and he thought maybe feces were
dumped there or something.
No, it turns out it was a baby
tower and it was just a pit dug
into the ground and surrounded
with this tower and people
brought excess girls especially,
but some occasionally boys and
just dumped them into this.
A little boy came up and
explained this to him and said
that--the little boy said that
four babies were thrown in that
morning.
This doesn't--this particular
passage didn't discuss the sex
of the babies because he didn't
know that, they're already in
there.
One of the quotes is,
"The female child is
regarded as a liability here.
In rural areas women are not
even considered people."
You'll do some reading where,
rather biased reading but
accurate on this,
that girls often don't get
names traditionally,
their named 'daughter number
one,' 'daughter number two,'
'daughter number three,' and all
kinds of things.
As I've mentioned the
elimination of females is not
limited to the young and in one
of your readings--
I guess I described it to you,
a tribe in New Guinea where if
a male died his widow was
immediately strangled.
Do you remember that?
That changes the sex ratio.
In India, you've all heard
about this, they're used to be a
variant to this practice called
sati.
You heard of sati or sutee,
sometime where the wife throws
herself on the funeral pyre of
the man or in some other way
does away with herself.
This is from 1813,
quite some time back,
and there was a British captain
named Kemp who was eyewitness to
one of these things and he wrote
a description of it.
" A male had been sick a
short time.
An astrologer said that he was
on the point of death and so he
was taken down to the side of
the holy Ganges River to expire.
He was immersed to his waist in
the river for some time,
but he didn't die.
They brought him back to the
bank of the river and let him
broil in the sun;
he didn't die.
Then they put him back in the
river again, and he didn't die.
He was returned to the
bank."
This kept going for 36 hours
alternating sort of freezing and
baking and finally this sick guy
died.
Whether he would,
or would not,
have died anyway,
who knows.
It was the astrologer's word
that he was going to die.
His wife, he was married,
was a healthy young girl of
about 16.
Learning of her husband's death
she decided to be buried alive
with his corpse.
The British officer,
this Kemp, tried in vain to
persuade the girl not to do it,
then tried to persuade the
mother, and he said that a
resolution of this type to just
kill yourself was a kind of
madness.
He had no success and he
encountered not the slightest
sign of either hesitation or a
great regret on either the
girl's part or the mother's
part.
The actual scene takes place;
the young widow accompanied by
her friends proceeded to the
beach where his body lay.
He was placed in a grave about
six feet deep,
the wife circled the grave
seven times calling out,
"Hail God,
Hail God."
the surrounding crowd echoed
her chant, 'Hail God,
Hail God.'
She climbed into the grave,
the captain,
this British guy moved up to
within a foot of the grave to
see if at the last minute she
showed any signs of reluctance
or whether her relatives showed
any sign of horror,
and if she showed reluctance he
might have jumped in and pulled
her out.
She placed herself in a sitting
posture,
as her husband had been placed,
didn't lay him flat but a
sitting posture,
both faced north,
so she was sitting behind his
back.
She embraced the corpse with
her left hand and reclined her
head on his shoulder.
The British officer still saw
no sign of regret on her part.
The other plan--the other hand
she placed over her head with
her forefinger erect which she
moved in a circular direction.
The watchers then started
throwing earth on them to start
burying them and then other men,
as the earth was put in,
they stamped on the earth to
pack it down but she continued
circling her hand until her head
was completely buried and then
she kept going for some time
after that and finally stopped.
The earth was piled on and
stamped down and was two or
three feet above the heads of
the entombed.
No tear was shed by any of the
relations.
Eventually the crowd disbursed
and the ritual lamentations and
howling commenced but without
sorrow.
This is a long time ago and
it's certainly extremely rare
now, if it happens at all.
There was one report of one
woman in a village about ten
years ago who did it,
and this is illegal in India,
so very hard to get any decent
statistics,
but very rarely it happens and
this woman who killed herself on
her husband's pyre was
considered a paragon of virtue
and sort of like a saint because
she was following the old
religious customs and the
village was happy about it
because they got a lot of
tourists to come and revere this
saint like lady and made a lot
of money off the tourists,
but it's very rare.
Of course this whole sex
preference business is not in
any sense limited to Asia.
Hispanic women in Los Angeles
were surveyed,
they want 2.8 sons on average
and 0.1 daughters,
a factor of 28 difference.
In Kuwait before the Gulf War,
this is the 1991 war I think,
Barbara Walters who you all
know, did a story on gender
roles in Kuwait.
Yes, during the Gulf War she
was there,
and she noted that women
customarily walked about ten
feet behind their husbands and
this happens in a lot of places,
and a strong sign of female
deference and dependence.
The husband walks without the
wife and the wife follows ten
feet behind, you've heard of
that custom.
The war takes place,
the Iraqi's get beaten,
she comes back to Kuwait to do
another story after the war,
and she was so pleased because
now the men walked behind the
wives,
that the women were walking in
front,
and so Barbara Walters said
this is wonderful progress,
this is the American--they're
catching on over there and so
she approached one of the women
and said--
and the camera was rolling to
catch this,
she's a TV personality,
"this is marvelous,"
says Barbara Walters,
"can you tell the free
world just what enabled women to
achieve this reversal of
roles?"
The Kuwaiti woman said,
"Land mines."
And so it wasn't a reversal at
all.
I think you get the idea of all
of this.
We--there's deeper reasons,
I mean again one way is to put
it down to Asian tradition and
that's not really any kind of an
explanation.
We like to think that people
are rational around the world
and that there's some more
fundamental reason for it.
A lot of the reasons that you
all said, what are some of the
extra reasons that I sort of
pushed aside for the moment?
One was dowry issues and some
of you said some other things,
but there's a whole lot of
things, and the basic story is
that in--
certainly in India and also in
traditional China the girl is
brought up by the parents,
gets married at quite a young
age, and by young teenage they
get married and get shipped off
to the son--
the husband's family where she
works is then counted in that
family and is worked--
usually works very hard and
basically is a servant in that
family.
The family that raises her has
the problem of investing in that
girl,
putting a lot of money to raise
that girl,
then, just as she's able to
start working seriously and
maybe return some labor,
some serious labor or some
money to the parents,
she's gone and she works for
some other family.
This is economically a very bad
thing and the people call
raising girls like watering
someone else's garden.
Then on top of that when the
dowry system is strong,
which it is in India,
and going crazy,
then at marriage they have to
provide a lot of money and this
can go up to be like a year's
income,
easily, to get the girl
married, and it's a great honor
thing.
If you have a daughter you have
to get her married,
so you have to pay dowry or
your family's honor goes away.
This idea, that the girl is
just passed away just at the
time she can be of value to you,
is kind of the rational actor
theory of why there's all this
female discrimination.
Anything strike you unexplained
about that?
Why is that--
Student:  It's the girl.
Prof: It's the girl that
goes away all the time.
Why can't the man go away?
This is, by the way,
characteristic of human
societies.
I may have mentioned this to
you, the genetics shows that
males in a village are related,
they've stayed there for
hundreds or thousands of years,
and females move out,
so exogamy.
Where have you seen exogamy
before?
Among the chimpanzees where the
females go out;
and so as far as we can tell
this is a vestige from our very
original biological roots where
our reproductive system requires
not that the males fight each
other and the males disburse but
that the males stay together in
a military situation and the
females go out.
It's this very basic form
of--you can call it chimpanzee
social organization that leads
to that.
The females go out and
therefore the females are of no
value to the family that brings
them up and therefore they're
discriminated against.
The men stay together and they
have to have a
protective--protect the village
against violence.
In some places there's
a--either a tribe or a caste as
you'll call it in India,
the Nayar, which are very
military kind of cast.
What happens is they get
married very young,
but then the man may,
or may not, spend one night
with the wife and then he goes
off to the military,
and meanwhile,
the wife has all kinds of
sexual relationships and its
quite formalized,
quite legal,
the women live in one big
house,
they don't really
recognize--it's like the Na that
you read about,
it's a female lineage society,
and then upper class men are
invited in to sleep with these
women and produce babies for
them,
and then the men have 15 or 20
years of military service.
Then they come home,
and only really at that time,
do they pick up the marriage.
Again it's a very clear--in
this particular cultural
manifestation,
it's a very clear thing that
women are the reproducers,
men are the military ones,
and, as in chimpanzees,
sort of a communal sexuality
that who's the biological father
is not particularly important.
Now, I want to switch gears
here in the time we have left,
and this whole lecture is about
South Asia,
and South Asia and East Asia
are the centers of female
disadvantage,
but that doesn't go on in all
of South Asia.
As I've mentioned,
in Muslim countries that
basically does not happen.
We're going to talk next about
two places;
one is Iowa and the other I'll
tell you in a moment.
Iowa is a rich place, right?
What is Iowa rich from?
Agriculture,
corn, it's a very,
very fertile place.
Well let me go back a little
bit, so I will tell you the
country that I'm going to talk
about if I can find it.
Again we worry a lot and have
induced some of the Asians to
worry about the sex ratio,
that all these men won't get
married,
but remember we're seeing sex
ratio disturbances of 12% to
20%,
and remember in Europe I showed
you this slide that a lot of
places only 30%,
or 40% or 50% of people got
married,
so the marriage imbalance is
much--was much more severe in
Europe for hundreds of years
than it is now in Asia.
The marriage pattern and the
social system in Europe made for
a more extreme situation than
the female disadvantage in Asia.
This not a great slide but this
is Bangladesh and what's in
Bangladesh is this the Himalaya
mountains and here's China,
and Nepal, Bangladesh over
here, India over here,
and this is blown up a little
bit and what you see is this is
the Bay of Bengal.
Here is the Ganges River comes
out of the Himalayas.
The Himalayas stretch all
across here,
the Ganges comes out of the
western Himalayas,
the Brahmaputra comes out of
the eastern Himalayas,
Bangladesh has lots of water
and this is all delta.
You see this stuff,
this is all delta from--through
geological time as the river
wanders around it puts down a
delta out here.
This is what the delta actually
looks like.
There's a reading that you have
which says that the place is so
bad that people are trying to
move out onto this land and try
to farm on it,
and then of course a monsoon
comes so the river--
the water rises and they're
wiped out.
You'll have a reading about
that, so keep this picture in
mind when you do that reading.
Now let's do the story on
agriculture.
The people in Bangladesh are
Bengali's of course and the
Bengali's are a large group that
are split actually between
Bangladesh and eastern--
northeastern part of India,
Calcutta is the capital,
Dhaka is the capital in
Bangladesh,
and Calcutta is the capital of
West Bengal which is part of
India,
so partition split Bengali's
into two groups.
Bangladesh is a very homogenous
country between Pakistan,
India and Bangladesh the three
ones are the old British Raj.
98% of them are Bengali's so
they speak the same language,
have the same cultural
tradition and 88% are Muslim.
Unlike India,
which you cannot talk about as
a whole, you can really talk
about Bangladesh as a whole.
Bengal is a very rich part of
the world,
the Moguls who ruled from the
thirteenth--
so the Moguls were Muslim
invaders from--
apparently I think from
Afghanistan,
conquered north India north of
that part,
and they ruled it from the
thirteenth century onward.
They called Bengal the paradise
of nations.
In the sixteenth century when
European traders came they were
ecstatic over Bengal's abundance
and riches.
Why was it so rich?
I want to compare it to Iowa.
The size of Bangladesh is
56,000 square miles.
Guess what the size of Iowa is?
56,000 square miles,
so they're very close to the
same size, both are very
basically agricultural.
Maytag makes washing machines,
or used to, in Iowa,
but they're very heavily
agricultural,
but Bangladesh has much better
climate than Iowa.
They grow three crops a year in
Bangladesh.
It's nice and warm there all
the time, but poor Iowa,
anybody from Iowa here?
They can only grow one crop a
year and they grow winter wheat
some, but basically it's one
crop a year.
Bengal they can grow three
crops a year.
Bangladesh has plenty of water,
I showed you,
they have nothing but water
there so they never have
droughts, and Iowa is not bad
for that.
It has the Mississippi River on
one side,
the Nebraska River on the other
side,
but inside Iowa the rivers are
all very small,
so if you go to the edges
there's rivers but inside not a
huge amount of rivers and they
sometimes have droughts there.
Both are fertile;
Bangladesh shows a low alluvial
plain so the way land gets
naturally fertilized is water
rushing--
glaciers on the mountaintop
grind the rock and that glacier
flour,
as it's called,
gets into the river,
dissolves somewhat in the
river, and during flood season
it spreads all this silt over
the farmland and that silt--
the minerals in the rock are
the fertilizer.
Bangladesh has this--these
floods from the Himalayas that
cover basically the whole
country and it gets it
fertilizer for free,
it gets as lot of fertilizer
and it gets it all for free,
so again the agriculture is
looking real good.
Iowa does not get this except
at the margins when the
Mississippi floods and sometimes
the Nebraska floods,
so the interior of the country
they have to go and buy
fertilizer there.
By all these geographical kinds
of considerations and climatic
kind of considerations,
Bangladesh should be much
richer than Iowa.
You compare three crops a year
to one crop and something like
three times as rich.
Bangladesh's per capita
income--Iowa's income is 17
times larger than Bangladesh's
and the difference is basically
all population.
Iowa's population is 2.9
million;
Bangladesh is now about 140
million, so it's like 40 times
difference.
Bangladesh has 40 times as much
population as Iowa.
Compared to every other place
in the world,
here are a variety of places,
here's Bangladesh way,
way out in front of everybody
else.
Netherlands is considered
of--other places--
the next most crowded place and
it's also an agricultural place,
but--both of these--they don't
have big mountains or deserts or
anything,
so all of the Netherlands is
basically fertile and all of
Bangladesh is basically fertile,
but look at the difference in
population density and everybody
else is less than either of
those two places.
As you know,
as I've just mentioned,
the income in Bangladesh is
distressingly poor,
it's one of the poorest
countries in the world,
and the estimates are that its
population may double before,
if and when stabilizing.
It's going to be very hard to
make things better in
Bangladesh.
Well going back,
Bangladesh had a stable
population,
they had a kind of traditional
birth,
very high birth,
very high death rates so the
population grew very slowly if
at all,
but about 1880 population
started to take off,
that's when again colonialism
and what not--
the death rate started to
decline and they started adding
about three million people every
decade.
What do three million extra
people do in a country the size
of Iowa?
Not tiny but not especially big
either,
well there's some jungle--there
was some jungle in Bangladesh,
they cleared that and they
started farming but by the late
1930s the jungle was just
totally gone,
no more jungle land.
In 1938, Biren Ganguli,
a Bengali himself,
wrote "Every inch of land
that is fit for cultivation is
already used.
Every pathway or cattle track
is pared down by farmers on
either side until he barely
leaves room for two people to
pass each other on this narrow
track."
What did people do as the
population kept increasing?
They started moving out onto
these mud flats that I've shown
you that are very temporary.
The cyclones come in,
not only is there the normal
flooding from the rivers,
but the cyclones come in and
you start getting these enormous
death tolls in a period of time
in Bangladesh from climatic
problems,
but it was really,
again, a population problem,
just like the deserts that I
told you about.
People shouldn't be living on
these flats where they're going
to be wiped out periodically.
There was, for a while,
almost 100,000 deaths a year
from storms,
erosion and flooding from these
kind of--
just consider deaths from
climatic water stuff.
It took about 60 years of the
population increase for Bengal,
becoming one of the--to go from
one of the rich places of the
world,
not industrialized,
but rich on their agricultural
produce to what was standardly
described as a basket case.
Now all the focus is on Africa,
but, not so long ago,
Bangladesh was considered in
just as bad shape as Africa is
now.
It was constantly on the news,
stories of disaster in
Bangladesh and you're supposed
to cry at that and give money.
Bangladesh was clearly one of
those places that was caught in
one of these Malthusian traps.
The arable land and this is a
somewhat old figure in the
population has increased a lot,
is 0.1 hectare per person,
that's a quarter of an acre a
person.
Just to compare you to that,
any of you from farm places?
How many of you are from farm
places?
Every year I always get
some--do you know what--what's
the size of the farms where you
live?
Where do you live?
Student:  I live outside
of Cleveland.
Prof: Outside of
Cleveland?
Student:  Yeah.
Prof: That's not one of
the big farms,
but do you know roughly the
size of the farms?
Student:  30 acres.
Prof: Thirty acres.
Student:  A small one.
Prof: Okay,
so that's small farms,
out West they can be thousands,
like the real commercial farms,
thousands of acres.
Here's 0.1 hectare per person.
I used to live in Bethany which
was sort of a northwest suburb
of New Haven and our house was--
our part of Bethany was zoned
for three acres and I didn't
have to live off of it,
there was just a house on that.
If you had a house you had to
have three acres so that was
enough so that,
in Bengal, Bangladesh 30
families would live on these
three acres at 0.1 hectare per
person.
All of the indicators in this
time starting,
say in the 1950s or 1960s,
was that Bangladesh would not
be a country in which you
would--
where you find a desire to
limit fertility or the practice
of fertility limitation.
It's, as I've said,
almost all Muslim and it's a
conservative version of Islam
there.
Infant and child mortality was
high,
25% of the children died before
the age of five,
but that had been coming down
slowly as I showed you for
roughly 20 years.
Women had very low social
status there,
most of them in--were subject
to purdah,
which they not only have to
dress so they can't be seen when
they're outside of the house,
but they generally couldn't go
outside of the house at all
unless accompanied a male member
of the family.
Men were fairly free to abuse
women,
and I read you the first
lecture I think some case of the
battery acid being thrown at
women in more recent time,
so that still continues.
Last time I mentioned that one
of the reasons that people want
children is for old age
security, who's going to take
care of me in my old age.
And, of course,
Bangladesh was very poor,
had no social security system,
so the families were,
of course, dependent on
children for their old age,
they were dependent on sons for
their old age,
so that means that you had to
have a lot of children to make
sure.
You can't have a daughter,
you've got to have sons to make
sure that you have somebody to
take care of you.
During the period of time I'm
going to talk about here are
some of the major disasters in
Bangladesh over time,
so this is one really very
famous one,
the Bengal famine of 1943.
They were already on the edge,
and then World War II hits and
a variety of things happen and
2.5 million people die in the
famine.
Here's some of the cyclones,
various cyclones.
They had a war when they were
trying to get independent of
West Pakistan,
they had a war and these things
happened,
another cyclone,
floods, all of them,
and so all kinds of problems
beset the country.
Now during this period,
that is the critical period for
population issues,
the per capita GDP,
the gross domestic product,
basically didn't change,
a little bit up but not
enormously up.
It basically had a flat per
capita economy,
per capita GDP,
so again, the total economy was
growing but more and more people
ate it all up,
so basically the per capita GDP
doesn't change in this period.
What happened was that Malthus
had been in India and the
Indian--
the whole Indian subcontinent
paid a lot of attention to
Malthus,
so they had been aware--India,
Pakistan,
Bangladesh had been aware of
population issues and aware of
the Malthusian ideas about it
for a long time and the British
of course trained their civil
servants of the countries when
they got independence it was the
same people,
so this was in their mind.
In fact the South Asia,
originally India and Pakistan,
were some of the very first
countries to institute family
planning programs.
The one in Pakistan was not
particularly successful,
the one in India is now much
better but did not start out
successfully,
but after the war of
independence,
when Bangladesh split from West
Pakistan the government really
was aware of these problems,
had a Malthusian attitude and
they really decided that they
must start to get some control
of their population.
The government supported and
instituted a family planning
program for the whole country
and international organizations
said,
'OK, you want to do this,
we will help you,' and
especially there's a group
called The International
Diarrheal Research Organization
which was one of the ones that
had discovered and pushed the
oral rehydration packets.
Many, many--huge numbers of
infant deaths in poor countries
due--
they get diarrhea and
diarrhea--the bug doesn't kill
you but you lose enough water
through the diarrhea that you
die basically of dehydration and
all you need to do is to have a
little packet of water,
salt and sugar and as long as
the water is not terribly
polluted the child will stay
alive and will eventually kick
out the virus or the bacterium.
This International Diarrheal
Research Group,
are very well respected,
and they said,
'okay we will also help you
with family planning programs.'
What resulted was a countrywide
program.
Now at this same time,
we're talking the early 1970s,
most of the developed world had
the idea that they--
what did they say,
they saw rich countries have
few children,
poor countries have a lot of
children,
what's the cause?
Well money is the cause.
When you get rich you want to
have fewer children,
we're going to have a lecture
on that very interesting
phenomenon.
A lot of developing countries
and East European countries
rejected the whole idea of
family planning as a way of
improving the economy and said,
no development is the best
contraceptive.
That was the rule,
development is the best
contraceptive,
that there's no way in,
a poor place like Bangladesh,
that you're going to get
fertility down because of all
these reasons that we've
mentioned,
but if you develop the country
economically than it will
naturally come down and the
government doesn't have to mess
with it,
doesn't have to set up family
planning programs.
Everybody predicted,
strenuously,
that Bangladesh could do what
it wanted with family planning
programs until and unless they
developed economically there
would be no progress.
What they did was they--prior
to this program they had tried a
variety of things.
In Pakistan one of the programs
was,
well people are culturally into
having a lot of children and so
we must work with their culture,
and must work with traditional
birth attendants.
In Pakistan,
including Bangladesh at the
time,
they had women called Daiys who
are basically local health
providers,
herbal women,
midwives for births and stuff
like that,
but they had basically no
modern training whatsoever.
In the first implementation of
Pakistan's program they gave
these Daiys various forms of
birth control and they were
supposed to give them out.
It didn't work.
Why didn't it work?
The Daiys themselves were older
women in general who did not use
contraception and did not think
it was moral,
did not think it worked,
and had all kinds of bad
attitudes toward it.
So, if someone tries to sell
you something,
and they don't themselves
believe in it,
you generally don't accept it.
Plus, economically,
they made very little by
distributing these kind of
contraceptives from the
government,
but they could make quite a bit
more by attending the births
that they charge a good fee for
births where the government set
the little bit,
they wanted to have the
contraceptives very fairly free
to the people,
so they didn't pay the Daiys
very much.
The Daiys would get all the
condoms especially and sort of
bury them somewhere and claim to
the government that they had
distributed them and then made a
lot of--
not a lot of money,
but their money from attending
the births that hadn't been
averted by this,
so it didn't work.
They learn, these are again the
first countries in the world to
have family planning programs
and they didn't know how to do
it.
You have to--it's not given
that this is the way you do it.
Eventually they started the
program that I described to you
somewhat last time where the
women can't come out of the
house so you hire a high status
woman from that village,
known to the women,
has high status,
is herself using contraception,
thinks it's a wonderful thing,
you train her how to deal not
only with the woman but the
woman has very little power
there,
to deal with the husband,
to deal especially with the
mother-in-law,
and for that you need a high
status woman that can go into a
house and start discussing these
things,
because even talking about
anything to do with sex or
reproduction is not a socially
acceptable thing.
They started this program and
initially you got this kind of a
thing.
Veena Siddharth talked about
this, that when you start a
family planning program,
this is an older version of the
family planning program not the
one I've just described.
What you see is they
took--there was a place called
Matlab,
one of the districts in
Bangladesh,
and they chose some villages,
they wanted to know if what
they were doing was successful,
some villages they gave this
family planning program to and
other villages they didn't,
as a control region.
Here is during this period up
until 1977 the comparison area
where they didn't do anything
special.
The government had a small
program but nothing much was
happening.
Now, the International
Diarrheal Research Group comes
in with this somewhat updated
program,
not the one I showed you,
and what happens immediately
there's great success and
they're jumping up and down,
okay this is true,
but then it peaks and then over
time it falls down.
What's happening here is a
small fraction of the women--
well 20% is not terrible,
but a small fraction of the
women,
before the program comes in,
want to limit their births.
You give them anything,
they accept it immediately.
That this initial rise and
that's very standard for family
planning programs.
That you get an initial rise
and then it falls off,
and over the long term if
you're evaluating the program
here you think it's wonderful,
but if you're evaluating the
program here it's kind of
worthless.
Veena was talking about that,
that she comes out of this
economic World Bank perspective
and they're very impressed with
these periods of time.
This is a program that,
in retrospect,
we would say really didn't
work, although it helps a fair
fraction of the women.
Then you put in the good
program that I described to you
and now what happens,
the later time,
so we stop the previous--
the previous graph stopped in
1977 at this level of
contraceptive acceptance,
so they had a program that
didn't work,
and then they start sending
these village working women into
the homes of the other women and
now you get another big rise,
that this is now successful
immediately,
but now the success continues.
Meanwhile there's modernization
and there's social diffusion
that these areas,
the comparison areas are
actually intermixed with the
treatment areas,
and they hear a lot about
what's going on in there and so
for that reason and others are
not--
we don't really have data to
say why a rise,
but even in the comparison area
it starts to rise.
In one of your readings about
Taiwan where you have family
planning, a very similar kind of
thing.
It makes a big point that,
they did have some data,
that they had villages where
they had a family planning
program,
and then as soon as this was
heard about in the surrounding
regions people would come into
the treatment region to get
treatment so fertility goes
down.
One of the factors behind this
is certainly diffusion of the
ideas of family planning.
This thing in Bangladesh has
had terrible significance for
what we believe about family
planning programs and people's
acceptance of it,
because up until this time it
was really dogma that you have
to have economic development and
you have to have a degree of
literacy,
and you have to have some
degree of women's status before
people would want to limit their
fertility.
Then you go into Bangladesh
with a well funded,
well thought out,
well run program,
and it starts working.
Now Bangladesh is--its
fertility has kept falling and
it's in there with a lot of
countries that are a lot richer
than it.
India is as lot richer,
Egypt is a lot richer than
Bangladesh, and they all now
have come to more or less the
same kind of fertility level.
It now is no longer really
believed--
it's believed that women almost
everywhere,
in this case it must be the
men, because the men and the
mother-in-law's control the
issue--
really do want to reduce
fertility and if you give them
the option,
they will accept it.
Along the way other places have
learned other lessons,
so India next door had a much
stronger central government
because of the Gandhi effect,
Gandhi was such a national hero
to all the ethnic groups in
India,
so the government was strong
and Nehru was very strong,
and Nehru's daughter
Mrs. Gandhi was very strong,
and they were Westernized,
under the Malthusian influence,
and they decided that they need
a family planning program also.
Actually India was even before
this, but again they didn't know
to do it, and they decided to
use incentives.
That's when economists keep
telling us,
every time you take an
economics course,
people respond to incentives
and so they decided to use
incentives to get people to take
on family planning.
There's a lot of debate about
this issue of incentives and one
part of it,
one article I read about people
in villages in Nepal like the
one that Veena was in,
pretty far.
They have to take a whole day
off from work to go down to get
a contraceptive,
then they have to go back,
and what kind can they get,
because they can't go this
every month to get something
new,
and they can't take time off
from their work or their chores,
so it's a real major economic
expense.
Not the contraceptive itself,
but the time and effort needed
if they have to take a bus,
it may be very expensive in
their economy.
So part of the idea of giving
incentives is to just repay the
woman for her time and effort.
India had started out that way
but the program was not very
well run,
it wasn't--they didn't have the
big international help that
Bangladesh had and the program
wasn't terribly well run,
and so they sort of got
frustrated at the results and
their population kept going and
there was a time in India,
way before this current boom
that India is--
has been going through,
and may or may not still be
going through,
and so the government got
frustrated and the population
grew and they saw their hopes,
there's this window of
opportunity that I was talking
about from modernization,
if the population gets too
dense that window may close.
The government got desperate
and started introducing some
coercion,
some of it is incentive like
transistor radios to the men--
to get the men to get
sterilized and that was
wonderful but who got
sterilized,
the old men that weren't going
to have children anyway,
but I get a transistor radio or
some money out of this.
The whole thing crashed and it
came entangled as in America,
reproduction and politics,
so the opposition to the--
people didn't especially like
it because it's changing their
culture.
But, the opposition took hold
of it and blew up all the
abuses,
no question there were abuses,
blew up the abuses,
the newspapers blared the
abuses and it became a very big
political thing and the Congress
Party government fell because of
that.
India has since sort of--then
they went through a period where
they sort of did nothing in
family planning because it was
in such bad favor and now
they've started up again and
things are going a lot better.
I think the story of this is
that the idea which was
prevalent up until the
Bangladesh experiment,
that only rich countries are
going to reduce their fertility
is just plain wrong,
and now as the fertility
transition goes through Asia,
it's now amazing,
places--very poor places what's
happening there.
Ceylon was one of the first
countries in Asia to get down to
replacement level,
very poor, Ceylon is not a rich
place,
Kerala one of the poorest
provinces of India is down at
replacement level;
all kinds of countries
Thailand, Indonesia,
all have really reduced their
fertility at amazingly low
levels of per capita income.
Income is clearly important,
one doesn't want to throw it
out,
it's perfectly clear that
things are easier if you have
more money and there's reasons
why richer people have fewer
children which we'll go into but
it is not a necessary
prerequisite.
We will see--have a good
vacation, enjoy,
come back refreshed and I will
see you then.